what's the the most favorite
your favorite thing you've ever done
what's the
you look at it you go this was the best
thing i've ever done like if i want
somebody hush see
that's what i thought i mean i don't
think that's the best i think it's like
one of the best but i mean haunting of
hill house midnight mass i mean all
these these are all great what was it
i wrote it with mike
it was the
accumulation of
30 years of my life that i poured into
that person day by day get up in the
morning and run before set i left set
every day feeling i had left everything
i had on the field i was so
happy
the level of happy i was
maybe mirrors only the birth of my
children
in terms of like in my wedding day in
terms of just like that was 18 days six
days a week night shoots every night
like a no money no nothing skin of our
teeth
film
and
oh i have my old teeth and hush
you did
your teeth weren't bad i would have i
would have said man that girl's got some
crazy grill
but i didn't say that yeah my old teeth
are in hush i didn't notice they were
bad i think you're just too hard on
yourself
oh man yeah just put that on a t-shirt
for me i should tattoo them it's like
that's like if i had a business card it
would say kate siebel too hard on
herself yeah i think we're all like that
i think a lot of people are i think i
think it's it's just one of the things
as i get older i'm just like stop just
be good to yourself
you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up it's okay
try not to do it again you did it again
you gotta change your ways dude but
don't hate yourself for it you've got
some kind of [ __ ] going on why do you
repeat these bad things that you do
you know and just because it's not gonna
help you just [ __ ] on yourself it's
just gonna bring you even lower so you
know and if you need help you get help
you get i go to therapy i [ __ ] talk
to somebody i keep doing these things i
don't i don't know why i keep doing that
like well how do we stop that and then
you get help from someone who knows what
the [ __ ] they're talking about and like
you make changes